you know there's a lot been going on
with you man yeah yeah what brought you
back to uh kind of leaving the major
label system and getting back to what
you what you know best
um you know what for me it was like
when
when i when i partnered with you know a
major
it was a cool experience because it's
like damn you know you have this budget
for everything everything you're doing
is coming out at like the top tier
things but you start realizing pretty
quickly like
there's not much that they can do
for your music to like explode at this
this expectation that they've set you
right now you know what i mean like
really all of my set success was
organic
as [ __ ] you feel me like
my marketing
advice from people i was working with
was to do this
you know what i'm saying and it's like a
while you're getting paid for this and
there's no [ __ ] they're getting paid a
lot for that right you know and and you
got to recoup whatever they're getting
paid exactly and so in and there's no
like shade to them at all because my
time working with atlantic was awesome
but i just realized i'm like oh
financially it makes way more sense for
me to just
do this thing myself because
that's all they're asking me to do
anyways just be you and hopefully some
pops off but if it doesn't pop off we're
going to be like
uh disappointed you know what i'm saying
and now it's like
being independent i'm getting back to
just making music because i think it's
cool not because you're chasing i'm
chasing some sort of smash yeah and
especially for me the smash record they
want me to chase is like
a diamond song like yeah you know what i
mean like i cannot repeat
that success for you at the drop of a
dime
and also i don't want to spend the rest
of my career trying to repeat that for
y'all